they came from beyond the world from
over the world from under the world they
came from inside the stars and from
behind the rain they came from the known
lands and they came from the secret
places of old the vast ones who drank of
the nebulae the small ones who did not
care what happened beyond the banks of
their rivers the ones who bathed in the
light and the ones who watched from the
shadows the ones who loved us and the
ones who forgot about us the ones who
hate us now and the ones who love us
still the ones who sung with the rats
and the ones who swam with the
leviathans they came from far and near
they came one and all they came to end
the world as you may already know from
our previous video in this series a
mysterious being known only as the
harbinger unlocked scp-001
the lock and brought about the
omnipocalypse every single
world-destroying xk-class scenario on
the books from foundation files to the
most ancient mythological tomes and some
we'd never even imagined began to come
true a world flooded with terrifying
anomalous activity from unfurling skies
to giant nightmarish animals was about
where we left off now it's time to open
your eyes and wake up this is the kind
of nightmare you can't encounter while
you're asleep
scp-5720 the astronomically inclined
crane went about its daily work the
small mechanical crane always occupied
itself with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning arranging esoteric
model solar systems but something was
different today
scp-5720 put the final touches on its
latest model and then lifted its
mechanical arm skywards pointing
directly into the vast and starry
infinity above but were they stars no
not today as
scp-5720 looked up at the sky
this time the sky looked back they
weren't stars they were eyes
something was coming towards earth from
the furthest reaches of the outer dark
an armada of world enders coming from
above below and all around a whole
cosmos of supremely powerful beings
zeroing in on our pale blue dot a
thought crossed through whatever passed
as the mind of this strange little crane
today
followed by another word ringing loud
and clear and holy as a mighty church
bell
and at that moment everything did
thousands of miles away a new god landed
on earth appearing like a great wall of
dense matted fur descending from the sky
ur
the mother of the ones that came before
after eons of absence she had eventually
returned to greet her children the true
rulers and stewards of this land but er
on oom was surprised and horrified by
what she saw their great cities their
sprawling structures their beautiful art
and advanced culture all gone laid to
waste by the worthless hairless apes
that once lurked in the forests with the
other animals something had happened
something
had changed the humans had slaughtered
her people destroyed their
accomplishments tarnished their legacy
driven the few that were left out of
their kingdoms and into the forests
treated them as mere animals and built
their hideous concrete cities over their
bones and they had the gall to call them
bigfoot or scp-1000
because thanks to them their beautiful
true name had been lost to time she
looked skywards and cried out in despair
and anguish at the loss of her children
inconsolable but then she felt something
a glimmer of hope in her mind the
possibility that things would change
that the humans would be toppled from
their thrones and true justice would be
achieved she called out to her remaining
children and her children answered
across the globe another great entity
awoke deep underneath a mountain when it
stirred into life and broke free it
shattered the entire mountain on top of
it as easily as you or me displacing a
bed sheet it took to the skies massive
but unseeable to the human eye it soared
through the air gazing down upon the
world it hadn't seen for thousands of
years once it had feasted on the blood
sacrifices of human subjects hoping to
avoid its wrath but humans weren't the
petty little group of huddled cavemen
that they had once been now they were in
their billions gathered in impossibly
large settlements the entities sought to
find a seat of power that it could
influence but now it was spoiled for
choice eventually it zeroed in and found
its perfect target an scp foundation
containment site here it would find a
new form to take and more petty pathetic
humans to bring under its mighty thrall
it landed in scp-765
the duck pond it is an anomalous pond
that is you guessed it full of ducks and
initially induces feelings of serenity
in its victims before later inducing
not-so-pleasant feelings when the entity
plummeted into the water it began to
absorb and bond with the anomaly growing
to epic sizes as it assumed a form that
the minds of us feeble humans could
comprehend a giant terrifying duck it
released a mighty earth-shaking quack as
it plodded across the countryside to
cause mayhem elsewhere in europe more
violent madness was unfolding a crimson
rooster cod then a golden rooster and
then a rooster of soot red anyone with a
basic knowledge of norse mythology was
shaking in their boots as a mighty beast
stirred in the heart of a desolate cave
the chains that had once held the
monstrous dog in place now broke it rose
and licked its jagged fangs excited to
stain them with the blood of its enemies
it was the great hound fennir omen of
the end times here to herald the end of
all things a trumpet boomed across the
globe with no apparent source people in
the streets in new york delhi london
cape town and countless other towns
cities and hamlets the world over paused
and listened in confusion below them the
great and terrible jormungadr the
thought to be mythological midgard
serpent stirred from its previously
eternal slumber and began to uncoil its
body the shifting caused earthquakes and
tsunamis along the coast of greenland as
towns and villages crumbled killing
thousands fenrir stalked along the
length of denmark slaughtering and
devouring anyone or anything unlucky
enough to cross its path but it did not
wage its war against mankind alone
behind it a hellish army of burning
giants marched mighty hands clutching
molten weapons ragnarok was upon us now
odin save us all and the administrator
slept she was the latest in a long line
of foundation staff members to hold that
hollowed position and in the dark vistas
of her dreams a predecessor approached
her he wasn't the old bearded man in the
heavy coat that she remembered now he
was wearing a 1950 suit and a fedora hat
and carrying a briefcase that's right
he'd taken up the mantle of
scp-990 also known as the dream man he's
a mysterious figure that appears to
members of the foundation in their
dreams warning them of impending
disasters that they may be able to
narrowly prevent if his warning is
heated though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his
message this time however his message
carried a different tone he told the
current administrator that there was no
way to stop the apocalypse from
occurring this time only making sure
that the particular shape of the
apocalypse would be the one most
favorable to the foundation and
humanity's joint interests all this was
devastating news that the new
administrator saw as a grievous betrayal
of both the foundation stances and
humanity as a whole she refused to
accept the idea that the apocalypse was
inevitable even coming from the mouth of
a former administrator as far as she was
concerned this dream man no longer
worked on the side of the foundation he
was in league with the world enders and
she refused to take his deal the scp
foundation would save this world from
the horrors the lock unleashed or they
would slide into the darkness with it
they would never work against the human
race
scp-343 also known as god awoken his
cell in site-17 the time for fun and
games with the humans at the foundation
had come and gone he was going by his
true name yahweh now he blinked and in
that same instant he was at site zero
the containment site for another scp-001
the legendary gate guardian all the
staff around them looked upon yahweh in
shock awed by the reality warper's
sudden appearance and unable to do
anything about it but really 343 was no
mere reality warper like some had
expected 343 truly was a god he just
didn't happen to be the only one in play
when the gate guardian saw yahweh now
standing before him he lowered his sword
spread his fiery wings and took a knee
in great reverence yahweh spoke calmly
but with unshakable authority
it
is the gate
lead my armies across the earth
the gate guardian uriel responded in its
booming voice
for the first time in recorded memory
the grand gate that uriel had always
been guarding opened revealing thousands
of legions of warrior angels waiting on
the other side they were impossibly
beautiful and powerful creatures each
won a vibrant glowing chaos of wings and
eyes wielding pure white swords and
singing resounding hymns of war soon the
air was thick with the chorus of
rustling wings as the angels loosened
themselves from the gate's mouth led by
yurio as yahweh's general into the
global fray
meanwhile back at site 10 another
scp-001
the item that started all of this the
walk was entering its next stage of
grand cosmic evolution something within
the lock suddenly unfurled causing a
shockwave that killed everyone at the
site and destroying the entire building
in an instant except in that same
instant all of the site-10 staff and the
building itself reappeared completely
unharmed in a field in new hampshire
back where site 10 used to be the lock
was doing some terraforming the ground
split open beneath into a mighty valley
the likes of which earth had never seen
before lush greenery sprouted within and
thousands of strange alien creatures
soon populated this new place in the
center the lock just floated in place
they were now ready for the first
meeting to take place over at site 2036
dr everett mann was working on a number
of
scp-098 specimens these are frightening
creatures reminiscent of spider crabs
with blades instead of pinchers and a
natural ability to mimic the sounds of
their prey he was studying the creatures
when he got a call asking him if the
specimens had acted up at all they had
already had sudden containment breaches
for scp-995
a type of dangerous carnivorous fungi
and scp-616
a mysterious airplane with satanic
elements to it just as dr mann was about
to reply the 098 specimens
metamorphosized into many winged flying
creatures which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls sirens blared all through the
facility and dr mann joined the many
other confused and frustrated foundation
staff members wandering the building
wondering just what the hell was going
on today they were getting bizarre
reports of unprecedented anomalous
activity from all over the world with no
explanation uniting at all according to
panicked whispers across the facility
emergency order patmos was now in effect
whatever that meant the true nature of
what was going on here went over most of
the heads of the scp foundation's staff
that's when man encountered dr charles
ogden gears who for such a famously
emotionless man looks surprisingly
worried dr mann tried to downplay the
situation saying they were only looking
at a handful of containment breaches
here nothing they hadn't handled before
dr gears shut him down with trademark
coldness feeling a little more nervous
now dr everett mann asked what else had
gotten out with steely eyes dr gears
replied
a whole damn lot now go check out
children of
scp-001 the scarlet king is scp-999
really his son and
scp-001 or borocycle the full-story
compilation for more interesting
explanations into scp-001